durch
[Musik]
zum schluss der sendung schauen wir auf
die brutale ordnung von unterdrückung
wie wir wissen ist sie nur mit
vernichtung aufrecht zu erhalten so auch
in den folterkellern des assad regimes
in syrien
wer etwa nach parcours kam erlebte die
hölle zehntausende wurden dort
inhaftiert nun waren ehemalige gefangene
ihr trauma aufarbeiten indem sie es noch
einmal durchleben der dokumentarfilm hat
moore zeigt ehemalige gefangene die ihre
erlebte qual
nach spielen hier errichten ehemalige
inhaftierte die kulissen für einen
dokumentarfilm
sie bauen den ort nachdem sie bis heute
über 15 jahre nach ihrer entlassung in
ihren albträumen verfolgt cudmore der
gleichnamige film von der seg
koproduziert in syriens gefürchtet zum
kern nur gehorsam
[Applaus]
viele libanesen und palästinenser
endeten eher willkürlich inhaftiert
nun gehen wir noch einmal zurück in
ihren alltag voller energie gung und
roher gewalt auf die wörter werden von
ehemaligen gefangenen dargestellt
weit davon entfernt im bernischen
gerzensee treffen wir einen der
beteiligten ali abou denn die der
regisseurin monika borgmann unterwegs
für die sache des verbrachte dort fünf
seiner insgesamt 13 jahre in haft
ein tag lichtemission immer folter
dauernd angst du weißt nicht hin zu
starten bei den metallen
nachdem sie die interviews aufgenommen
hatten ergab sich erst die form des
fenster die gespielten szenen in den
fällen waren dann in einem tag und einer
nacht betrieb wie männer wenn sie keine
worte mehr hatten standen wir auf
spielten nach dass man auch im prinzip
und das heißt uns war sehr schnell klar
dass worte nicht ausreichen um das
geschehene zu beschreiben und durch
diese form von huey in acting haben die
männer meiner meinung nach eine
ausdrucksform gefunden die ihnen absolut
entspricht
in diesem tag aus wir glaubten kaum zeit
und zurückzufallen in unser verhalten
von damals vor 15 jahren wurden
automatisch wieder zu gefangenen system
jetzt hat moore war richtig für deine
foltermethoden
das nenne hier an einem unbekannten die
von keinem anderen des lang wie aber
lässt sich dieses unfassbare grauen
überhaupt abnehmen
in diesem modell in dem film sind wir
nicht in alle details gegangen
wir wollen die zuschauer nicht
schockieren sie nicht abschrecken wie
bunt und sie konnten so haben wir uns
für eine auswahl an folterszenen
entschieden auf twitter und diese für
die zuschauer erträglicher zu machen so
du mir geht easy as much as we can't der
film hat zum ziel nicht nur folter zu
zeigen sondern hat auch zum fiel das
kleine geheimnis von jedem verein
spielen wie er überlebt hat der dreh hat
ihm geholfen
herr über ein kapitel ihrer
lebensgeschichte zu werden
tausende überlebten die folter nicht
alle abo den aber wurde im jahr 2000
begnadigt
nun hat er das trauma noch mal durchlebt
gleich nutzen
für mich hat sich damit wenig verändern
aber ich habe den film gemacht damit die
menschen von uns erfahren mit uns
mitfühlen können und vielleicht kann nur
von einer etwas für all jene tun sie
noch immer in gefangenschaft do
something for the others ein film als
starkes plädoyer für die unversehrtheit
und würde jedes menschen ab 9
märz im kino
[Musik]